today on the matt wall show i have
another big announcement to start the
show also after the slap heard round the
world the consensus on the woke left is
that it is in fact acceptable and
justified to physically assault someone
for mean jokes although there are a
number of important qualifiers that we
must take into consideration to
understand this rule we'll talk about
that also florida officially enacts the
anti-groomer bill while the pro-grooming
factions react with demonic pedophilic
fury the nfl also updates its diversity
rules to encourage the hiring of more
women because women are famously experts
when it comes to football and a male who
identifies as trans announces that he
has just had his first period and should
probably seek medical attention right
away and our daily cancellation
psychiatrists and pharmaceutical
industry have just announced that um
grief is now a mental illness and
there's a drug to cure it which will
make them even richer what a happy
coincidence for them we'll talk about
all that and more today on the matt
wells show
[Applause]
[Music]
values are now up 19 these gains have
become an important financial tool for
homeowners why is that because you're
able to access that equity as cash at
incredibly low interest rates making it
easier to pay off high interest debt
fund home renovations or do whatever you
need because it's your money after all
now if this sounds like something you're
interested in and it should be it's
worth a call to american financing to
learn more they'll provide a free
mortgage review so you can understand
your options before moving forward
there's no pressure there's no upfront
or hidden fees it's very simple very
easy instead they take the time to get
to know you so that they can find the
perfect loan to achieve your goals could
mean savings of up to twelve thousand
dollars a year
and uh plus tens of thousands long term
all of that money is available to you
all the savings are available to you
especially with with inflation with
everything happening in the economy
you've got to take advantage of any
savings you can find 866 569 4711 is the
phone number that's
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net american financing
nmls one eight two three three four and
mlsconsumeraccess.org
so we start today with some rather
significant personal news as you all
know i am already the number one
best-selling lgbt children's author in
american history and beyond that the
most revered and respected lgbt voice in
the world now you might think that much
that such an achievement would be enough
for one lifetime but um now i can add
another i am officially as of this week
a best-selling women's studies author
along with being a best-selling lgbt
lgbt children's author i am also now the
preeminent women's studies authority in
the nation
this development uh coincides with the
announcement of my new book what is a
woman and i told you about the what is
woman film which will come out in may i
also have a book titled what is a woman
one man's journey to answer the question
of a generation which is now available
for pre-order at amazon or you can go to
what is a woman dot com and get it there
as well i'd recommend that you go now
and order your copy because it's a good
book on an important subject and also
because
we both know that there is no choice now
but to ensure that i remain atop the
women's studies category for as long as
possible
now as for the book itself just like the
movie the question in the title what is
a woman is only the beginning of the
journey that's the doorway which takes
us into a deeper exploration of gender
ideology i spoke with many alleged
experts in the field and i discovered
many things that will shock and horrify
you over the past year i've i've been on
a strange and disturbing adventure but
at times it has also been hilarious
often in the darkest ways imaginable you
can read about it for yourself if you
pre-order the book what is a woman at
whatiswoman.com and look out for the
film which is coming soon now
as a best-selling lgbt women's studies
children's author
i've been thinking more about the
infamous will smith incident at the
oscars it's been interesting really
especially to view this story through
the marginalized lens of an lgbt women's
studies expert
my community is so often ignored in
these conversations no matter how many
best-selling books we write
so over the past day or so so um a
consensus has emerged on the left at
least among the race hustlers and other
members of its wokest factions the
settled narrative is that will smith
as a black man
ostensibly in defense of a black woman's
feelings
is entitled to lash out as violently as
he wants in whatever context he wants
that seems to be the sentiment now i
think a few viral tweets might summarize
things for us this one with 134 000
likes says chris rock's one joke was
rooted in misogynoir texturism and
ableism degrading a black woman in a
room full of her peers on live tv the
fact that y'all don't see that as
violent is beyond me
yes who has not flown into a violent
rage because of texturism
everyone in my life knows that texturism
much less texturism mixed with massaging
noir is my biggest pet peeve when i hear
texturism you know they can hear me
shouting from the other room is that
texturism are you guys doing texturism
in there
especially as a women's studies
expert they know don't bring don't bring
that mess around me
so i can understand that but still um
also someone in media named um shea
bully concurred posting
black emotions scare white people that's
quite clear y'all shook because you're
used to seeing your favorite black
people wear their masks
then a woman named grace randolph adds
will smith wins best actor he is still
clearly very shaken by what was said
about jada his choice to stand up for
her and the abuse that goes on today of
public figures people of color and more
he will surely speak on this more all
week as will others
the new york assemblywoman um by the
name of um i don't know her name but she
joined other politicians like ayanna
presley and jamal bowman in claiming
that chris rock's joke was a form of
violence she tweeted
it is violence to mock someone's health
condition and vulnerability it is
violence to physically assault someone
it is violent to not take responsibility
for violent actions it is violence to
allow and excuse violence it is violence
to call for violence
yes it's violence to excuse violence she
says as she excuses violence
meanwhile the media has gotten in on the
action usa today published an article
with the headline
jada pinkett smith chris rock and why
his hair joke was so problematic
and then forbes asked asks this question
in their headline why are jokes always
at the expense of black women
now
i can answer that um
jokes are not always at the expense of
black women in fact jokes are
almost never at the expense of black
women we might reasonably say that black
women are the least mocked and least
joked about group in the country perhaps
even beating out trans people for that
title
on the rare occasion
that anyone does tell a joke about black
women or about a black woman
individually it is always another black
person telling a joke
i can't remember the last time i've
heard a non-black person tell a joke
about a black woman
much less black women in general
on the other hand non-white people tell
jokes about white people and especially
white women all the time
the term karen is itself a derogatory
joke about white women which was first
popularized by non-white people
so karen is a joke that black people
tell about white people
there is no synonymous joke going the
other direction it doesn't exist
what's more i think we can all we all
know that
if chris rock had made a joke about a
white woman
i mean he's told many jokes about white
women many times for many years but if
on that particular night he had happened
to joke about a white woman and her
white husband strode onto the stage and
slapped him across the face
we could be quite sure that there would
be nobody defending him the guy doing
the slapping that is
and he would have been arrested and
charged with a hate crime before he
could even get back to his seat
that's the real lesson we could take
from this
and there are two others
related less to the incident itself and
more to the reaction on the left to the
incident first
we see how the racial victim narrative
is superimposed onto everything
regardless of the facts on the ground
it doesn't matter this was black on
black crime doesn't matter that the men
involved had the same race same
socioeconomic status same gender same
age same sexual orientation
you would think if you didn't know any
better that one rich black man slapping
another rich black man at the oscars
would be an event impervious to racial
tribalization
if there's any story that cannot be
intersectionalized it would be this you
might think
but you'd be wrong
the race hustlers as we've learned time
and time again they need only for a
black person to be involved that's all
the clay they need to mold the image
they want to mold from it and even if
there was no black person involved even
if this was white on white violence
you know leonardo dicaprio slapping tom
cruise or something like that which
would have been great by the way still
they could make black people the victim
second most importantly we see that the
left
is serious
when they say that words are violence
now of course that statement is heavily
qualified words
insulting or joking about
certain groups of people are violence
i mean you can of course say whatever
the hell you want about straight white
people chris rock could have done a
15-minute routine where he fantasized
openly about rounding up all the white
people in the room and burning them
alive
and it would have been considered
comedic brilliance
he could have actually rounded them all
up and really burned them alive and it's
arguable whether he'd be in jail right
now
that much is established
but words attacking or supposedly
attacking or simply just criticizing or
lightly mocking
members of a protected class are indeed
violence in the minds of a leftist
why well
this is where the story ties in with
everything else we're witnessing in our
culture it intersects with gender
ideology
which is a topic that i explored by the
way in my best-selling women's studies
book what is a woman available now for
pre-order what is woman.com for an
individual in a protected class
their their self-perceptions their
feelings especially their feelings about
themselves are just as important as
their physical well-being
that's the way it's seen in our culture
in fact even more important
remember in the modern world we have
assumed the power to make ourselves we
are forever engaged in the never-ending
process of self-creation
the most important version of yourself
is not your physical self your actual
self but the self you have constructed
in your imagination
physical violence cannot necessarily
touch your imagined self
which is your most important self again
but words can ideas can
ideas can even kill a person's imagined
self their self perception
and so in that sense words are violence
the worst kind of violence
this obviously applies most to a
person's so-called gender identity but
it applies to everything else
that they think and feel about
themselves
jada pinkett smith had spoken publicly
before the night of the oscars even
recently
about how she loves her bald head she's
proud of it she thinks it's beautiful
now that's obviously not true she
doesn't really think that or else she
wouldn't be so sensitive to jokes about
it i mean if you're really proud of
something and you think it's great and
beautiful and you have no problem with
it and somebody tells a joke about it
it's it's it's not going to make any den
at all on you it's just going to bounce
right off you because you you're
confident
so she's not really confident about it
as she pretends but she wants to think
that way about herself
that's the self-perception she is trying
to
conjure up and create and maintain
a joke obstructs that process
and so it's violence
it's violence against the version of
herself
she is trying to perceive
that's what they mean when they say
words or violence
it's all completely insane of course
but it's the world we're living in
nonetheless
and it's good to try to understand it to
the extent that we can
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know while there are many many
leftists out there just begging to be
canceled right now i'm going to give
them a little break not for very long
just until i get to the end of this
because i have a way bigger cancellation
to make and that is store-bought meats
yup that's what it comes down to it's
it's not a person but it's sold to you
by what we better hope the store-bought
meat isn't a person uh but it's sold to
you by people who do not care about you
or your health they hide behind the
smoke and mirrors of empty labels like
all natural cruelty free grass-fed
whatever any of that means that's why
i'm giving all of you my sweet babies a
chance to prove your loyalty follow me
on this righteous crusade to cancel
store-bought meat stop buying it instead
do yourself your family and the world a
favor and start purchasing your meat
from good ranchers why well not only as
good ranchers the exclusive meat company
the daily wire it's actually 100
born raised and harvested in the usa
that can't be said for 85 percent of the
grass-fed beef in stores that claims to
be from the usa but are actually
imported from overseas my point is
you're being lied to by big meat but
good ranchers is here to tell it to you
straight their meat is steakhouse
quality locally sourced in america
affordable and it ships straight to your
door and it's absolutely delicious i can
tell you from experience it's time to
cancel store-bought meat and i'm
ordering you to join me in doing so
you're not giving you an option so head
to goodranchers.com walsh or use
codewall should check out to get 30 off
the most convenient and delicious
purchase you've ever made go to
goodranchers.com walsh today so that we
can all say goodbye to store-bought meat
once and for all
all right as a best-selling lgbt women's
studies author i want to get right now
directly into the
five headlines
um
i'm gonna you know i'm gonna run this
joke into the ground it's just going to
be obliterated you're going to hear
about it so much but it's not a joke
it's actually real i really am a women's
studies expert
okay
we'll start with this from fox florida
governor ron desantis signed into law
monday a parental rights bill that bans
teachers from giving classroom
instruction on sexual orientation or
gender identity in kindergarten through
grade school or rather through third
grade not even grade school i just
overstated it that's that talk about
self perceptions and what what you want
to be real
that's what i wish this bill did i think
this bill actually should apply to every
level of school
where this stuff does not belong in
grade school at all
but it only goes into third grade it's
just pre-k
through third grade so like
four-year-old four years old to about
eight
you're not allowed to give instruction
official classroom instruction on sexual
orientation and gender identity so
teachers are not allowed to go to a
little six-year-old kid
and and sit down with them and say
what's your what's your gender identity
what's your sexual orientation
that's all they're being prevented from
doing
but as we know the groomers out there
are very very upset about this
so much of their
project
in the culture depends on being able to
indoctrinate groom abuse
um
little kids
and so if you stop them from doing that
you're going to get
this kind of satanic fury which is what
we've seen
um
and we know that the bill was mocked at
the oscar sunday night with co-host
wanda sykes amy schumer and regina hall
repeating the word gay as the crowd
applauded uh but desantis announcing it
hit back at his critics in hollywood
saying if the people who held up
degenerates like harvey weinstein his
exemplars and his heroes and as all that
if those are the types of people that
are opposing us on parents right writes
i think i wear that like a badge of
honor
they don't want to admit that they
support a lot of things that we're
providing perfect protections against
for example this again as desantis
talking they support sexualizing kids in
kindergarten they support injecting woke
gender ideology into second grade
classrooms and so what they're doing
with these slogans these narratives is
that they're trying to camouflage their
true intentions
very well put could have been said any
better let's listen to a little bit more
of rhonda sanders yesterday announcing
and uh talking about this this bill
and so uh we will continue to recognize
that in the state of florida parents
have a fundamental role in the education
health care and well-being of their
children we will not move from that i
don't care what corporate media outlets
say i don't care what hollywood says i
don't care what big corporations say
here i stand
i'm not backing down
well done uh this is
i i i've said it a million times i'll
say it a million more times this is what
every republican should be doing
um this is a winning issue
run on this issue
if there's a republican running for
office at any level as we head into the
midterms who is not running on this
issue it's not just that you mention it
from time to time run on this issue
of protecting children against sexual
indoctrination
why do you run on it because
it's
one of if not the most important issue
in our culture today
and also as a benefit
um
our view as conservatives is is a is the
winning view
you're putting the other side in the
position
of having to defend
the sexual indoctrination of of children
let them do that
that's all you have to do is just get
them talking
you know a republican in a debate all
you have to do is say okay so you think
six-year-olds
should be taught about sexual
orientation you want public school
teachers to sit down with six-year-olds
and tell them and talk to them at six
about their sexual orientation and
quote-unquote gender identity tell us
more about that well go ahead
i'll give i seed the floor to you i'll
give you five minutes go ahead and talk
as much as you want in fact
i won't say another word in this debate
i'll i'll just let you talk all you want
about how we got to talk to
five-year-olds um about about
transgenderism again i give you the
floor
i'll just sit back here and let you talk
that's all you have to do
it is it's a winner
but you got to stay on message
and you can't let them drift into
um the the fantasy world which is where
they want to take this
they know look they know that their
position on this issue is is
abhorrent
now it's not abhorrent to them
because they have no souls but they know
that it's abhorrent to normal people
if they didn't know that then they
wouldn't be going through all this
effort to invent bills that don't exist
like you know don't say gay they
wouldn't be going through all this
effort
making claims about this bill that are
easily debunked
you could spend just 30 seconds reading
the language of the bill
and see what an absolute lie their
narrative is and they wouldn't be doing
that if they didn't have to basically
because the other option
is um
well the real the one other option is to
stop trying to sexualize kids but that's
off the table for them they can't stop
they can't stop themselves
uh which is which is very common of
predators which is why predators should
all just be locked in prison and never
let out but so they can't stop
themselves but they also can't they
can't come out and make a case for it
so the more you can get them talking
about it put them on the hook
put them on the spot
the better it's a winning issue now
desantis he also brought um some parents
on to talk about why this bill is needed
because that's the other response from
people on the other side of this is uh
it's all right you know even if it's not
that don't say gay bill uh even if it is
a bill that just stops teachers from
sexually indoctrinating very young kids
is that is that really needed where is
this happening i mean where is this
happening in society except everywhere
where is this happening except every
single public school in the country
so i had a few parents talking about
their own experiences this kind of thing
and here's one mother telling a really
horrifying tale listen
in september of 2020 my daughter told me
after school she had a meeting with
school officials that was held behind
closed doors where they asked her which
restroom she wanted to use
i immediately contacted the school as
told by the guidance counselor and
assistant principal that i could not be
given any information regarding the
meeting and that by law my daughter had
to be the one to authorize my
notification of the meeting or
attendance to the meeting
in other words school officials asked my
13 year old child
her permission as to whether or not my
parental rights would be honored
after many weeks of going back and forth
with the district we learned the middle
school had created a transgender gender
non-conforming support plan with our 13
year old daughter without our knowledge
or consent
this kind of thing
uh you know if you have a
if you have a room full of parents you
could just throw
a rock which is what a lot of people on
the left would like to do
but you could throw something and you're
guaranteed to hit a parent who's who has
if they if they've got public kids in
public school
they might not have stories hopefully
many of them do have stories as bad as
that and as dramatic as that but they've
all encountered this kind of thing
this is happening everywhere
and that's why we need that's why we
need laws like this but we actually need
laws that are
much stricter and go much further than
that
because the law that was just passed and
again it's a great law i mean i'm i'm in
favor of
incremental gains if the other option is
no gain at all i'll take the
incrementalism as long as we keep going
and we're not satisfied that's my one
criticism i won fear with this uh with
this parental rights bill in florida is
that
republicans might be able to say now
well we uh we did it we protected
parental rights and we passed the bill
and let's move on to something else
if they do that that's a big problem
because all you've done here is offer
protection for the youngest kids which
is great
but kids in fourth grade need protection
too kids in fifth grade sixth seventh
eighth ninth tenth eleventh twelfth they
all need protection they're all kids
um there's quite a lot of this that
happens in elementary schools it really
kicks into high gear in middle school
because that's right around
you know the age of puberty and that's
when that's when the indoctrination
kicks into high gear
that's also when kids are the most prone
to being
uh confused
about their identity feeling out of
place
socially feeling out of place sort of
within themselves trying to figure out
where they fit in the world who they are
what kind of person they are
every kid goes through this it's the
most normal thing in the world
and it's it's it's even more common and
more pronounced for girls
given the changes that they're
that they're experiencing
where they start to feel kind of alien
in their own bodies
you talk to almost any woman and and
they'll they'll they'll tell you that uh
any woman listening right now can relate
to it to some extent to that have having
gone through that
now the danger now
most of us if we're adults
we went through puberty we went through
childhood we had the experiences of not
feeling not fitting in
you know not feeling totally at home
kind of figure trying to figure out who
we are and what we're all about and um
we all we all had that experience
all kids throughout history have had
that experience
but the difference is that you and i and
every other kid prior to the current
generation of kids going through school
right now we were basically allowed
to go through that
go through that phase and come out the
other end of it and grow up
and have a normal life we were given
space to do that
now you have these predators these evil
satanic disgusting groomers
who are waiting there to pounce
as soon as a child begins to have any
questions about themselves
begins to feel out of place at all
um it begins to have any questions about
their bodies and the changes that that
they're experiencing the moment that
happens these groomers are there to
pounce and say oh oh you're feeling that
way well i'll tell you why you're
feeling that way and they've got this
entire framework ready to go
here it is
i got all the answers for you
that's the difference
kids before this you went through that
phase you got you went you got over it
uh
but now
kids there's a lot of confusion also and
now they have this framework
they have this whole ready-made system
which appears to make sense of
everything that they're feeling
it actually doesn't make any sense at
all but they don't realize that
and then adding to the pressure they
look around at their friends and their
friends are all buying into this there's
a lot of social capital to be gained
you know our kids are going through
the situation for our kids right now in
schools is that
to be
you know to be just like a normal 13
year old girl
just a normal girl there there's no
social capital in that
you got to add something on to that have
some kind of extra thing you're adding
to your identity
find your place under the lgbt umbrella
that's where the social capital is
so this is happening everywhere um and
uh this is why we need bills like this
everywhere that in fact go much farther
than this bill goes
and let the groomers let the groomers
panic and scream and let them make their
case for sexualizing kids let them make
their case we want them to we want them
to make the case talk about it
take the mask off expose themselves
all right
um
meanwhile disney has issued a statement
they say florida's hb 1557 also known as
the don't say gay bill should never have
passed and should never have been signed
into law our goal as a company is for
this law to be repealed by the
legislature or struck down in the court
so we remain committed to supporting the
national state organizations working to
achieve that we're dedicated to standing
up for the rights and safety of lgbtq
plus members of the disney family as
well as the lgbtq plus community in
florida and across the country
so disney which produces
much of the entertainment um that your
kids probably watch
they have come out and
at first they tried to basically stay
out of it but now
caving to the pressure
i mean this is a company with thousands
and thousands and thousands of employees
billions of dollars
and a handful of them
came out and complained and were able to
bring disney the
disney corporation to its knees
you want to talk about social capital
that's the kind of power that you wield
if you're in the lgbt camp
going back to why why why so many kids
it's tempting for them to buy into it
because they see that
and they see the power and popularity
that comes with it
but disney caving to all the pressure
now they're
they're offering full of full defense
they are fully in favor of sexualizing
young kids
now of course we know that disney has
been in favor of that actually for for a
long time
but now they're out in the open about it
they think that your five-year-old
should be sexualized they think that
your five-year-old should be taught
about transgenderism and gender identity
and sexual orientation
now the question becomes
are we as parents going to continue to
purchase disney products
and sit our kids down in front of
televisions to watch entertainment from
disney
after disney has told us
that they are in favor of sexualizing
your kid that's what they want to do
they're they are committed to it they
say
they are steadfastly committed to the
sexualization of kids
been the case for a long time now
they're out coming out and saying it
they are fully out of the groomer closet
we have to make a decision now as
parents
um is
disney entertainment
so important so crucial to us as parents
that um we'll we'll continue to give
them our money even after they've told
us they want to sexualize our kids
or will we finally have a little bit of
self-respect and say you know what you
don't even have to call it a boycott
i mean call the boycott if you want i
don't care what you call it
but when a when a company comes out and
says number one
we hate you
we hate everything you stand for we hate
your values we hate who you are we hate
everything you believe and we want to
sexualize your kids
uh here's a whole bunch of entertainment
we've made for your kid please sit them
down in front of the tv and let them
watch it
as parents we have to decide uh is it is
are we gonna say well okay
be like brainwashed
hypnotized automatons and say oh okay
sit down kids and watch this what else
are we going to do
well a life deprived of disney products
is unlivable
who can imagine such a thing
it's about having a little bit of
self-respect and respect you know for
your kids
um all right in more groomer news libs
of tick tock has this that says these
are internal messages from a fourth
grade elementary teacher in austin
independent school district she's upset
that an entire week dedicated to lgbt
still wasn't good enough and
coincidentally 20 out of 32 of her
fourth graders are lgbt and have come
out to her
okay so we found we we talked last week
about in austin schools they've had they
had a pride week
which included having a forced pride
march through the hallways and they
decked all the kids out and rainbow
stuff and all that kind of thing and
they had signs and they were waving
flags and marched through schools
and they had community this was where
they had the community circles where
they'd sit all the kids around and
they'd tell secrets and they were told
don't tell anybody outside the circle
especially your parents about the
secrets
um
but
teachers are upset that this happened
not not because uh it was totally
inappropriate but because it shouldn't
just be a week it should be an entire
year
so here's this teacher
from an internal message fourth grade
elementary teacher
says i feel that it is inappropriate to
call our pride our parade this morning a
wellness walk while i understand that
wellness walk is something that was
previously in motion to promote health
and fitness and is something we want to
continue
really takes away from the experience of
celebrating pride to couple the two
the first pride was a riot it is not
enough to just welcome love and
celebrate queer folks folks with a with
an ex
your allyship should always lead you to
activism speaking up and fighting for
what is right even when it feels
uncomfortable we can't choose in and out
of our protest spaces
and then it continues
out of the 32 students that i teach
20 of them are
lgbtqia plus and have come out to me
i feel that we need to do better for
them to affirm our students i think it
would only be appropriate and right to
publicly announce that we had this
morning that what we had this morning
was a pride parade our students are
aware and are paying attention
okay so a big part of her problem is
that they had a they had a
march through the schools and there were
pride flags and everything but they
didn't specifically call it a pride
parade and that's what she's worried
about
but let's put all that to the side and
just focus on this detail for a moment
this is a fourth grade teacher saying
that 32 students
20 of them in fourth grade
are
lgbt she says and have personally come
out to her
20 out of 32.
um
that's as opposed to like everybody
else's experience if you're an adult in
fourth grade
and basically
no kid would have identified as lgbts it
just wasn't on the radar
you weren't thinking about it you
weren't talking about it
now 20 out of 32 she says
and she says it proudly this is not a
secret that she wants to keep
this is um
to call this a social contagion i think
understates the facts of the matter
but this is something unlike anything
that the world's ever seen
we are watching an entire generation of
children be re-shaped and reformed in
front of our very eyes
um
laws protecting kids is like the least
that that's that's starting level of
what we need to be doing
all right let's move to this al butler a
sports reporter has this says women will
now be included in all rooney rule
requirements in the nfl all 32 teams
will be required to hire a diverse
person
female or a member of an ethnic or
racial minority to serve as an
offensive assistant
and then he has the language from the
nfl
and it says this is what it specifically
says
offensive assistant coach
a former resolution was adopted to
provide greater opportunities for
diverse candidates to serve as offensive
coaches beginning this season all 32
clubs will employ a diverse person
so the person themselves
the actual individual person is diverse
it used to be when you think of
diversity
if we're talking about diversity among
people that's like a group of people
could be diverse because you have people
of from various different backgrounds
and cultures and whatever um all in the
same room that's a diverse group
now we say that an individual person is
diverse or non-diverse does that make
any sense whatsoever no of course it
doesn't
uh it says this person will receive a
one-year contract and work closely with
the head coach and offensive staff to
gain experience clubs will receive
reimbursements from a league-wide fund
towards the coach's salary for up to two
years
in recent years head coaches have
predominantly had offensive backgrounds
we believe this resolution will assist
greatly in continuing to source and
identify diverse candidates earlier in
their careers providing pipeline depth
and furthering developing the diverse
offensive pipeline
then it goes on from there
so we already knew about the rooney rule
that's put in place requiring that teams
at least interview
uh well we used to say interview black
candidates for coaching jobs now we
might say diverse candidates diverse
individuals for coaching jobs
and the real update here is that um
they're putting women into that
into that category as well
trying hoping to work towards
a day
where there will actually be a female
head coach in the nfl
you know a female who is a
leader of men
leading all of these you know
all of these uh professional athletes
all these men we're gonna have a woman
leading them into battle on the football
field
that's what the nfl wants to see anyway
and they're you know they they have at
this point stopped short and eventually
they're going to get to this point i
think where they're going to have to do
this
because no matter how many diversity
requirements they put in place it's one
thing you have the diversity
requirements requiring the interview
black candidates that's that's
okay i mean it's absurd to have any of
these requirements at all
but one of the reasons why it's absurd
to have this in place for black
candidates is that
there there are black people working at
every level of the nfl
um
but if you want to have a woman
as a coach in the nfl
and if the goal as it says there is
eventually because you want to you know
it's it's put them in the pipeline so
that eventually they can be head coach
if you want that to happen then the nfl
is going to have to eventually come in
and just point to a team and say you
must hire a female head coach
my guess is in the next five years
that's what they're gonna do
all right moving on democrats are hoping
that katanji jackson will uh help you
know
alleviate some of the some of the
polling problems they're having right
now um
the latest poll on buy now how the
numbers are in front of me but it's it's
you thought he'd already gone as low as
he could possibly go and it's even lower
than that
so they think that uh the fact that he
nominated kantanji jackson is a thing
that's going to make a lot of people
excited so they're still talking about
it heaping praise on kantanji jackson
yesterday cnn actually ran a piece
praising jackson not only for being such
a wonderful justice but also for her
physical beauty as well listen to this
judge jackson isn't only changing the
image of justice but the image of beauty
unfolding on a small device my parents
were public school teachers a big moment
in america they gave me an african name
katanji onyika which they were told
means lovely one the senate confirmation
hearings for judge katanji brown jackson
capture chicago stylist portia egbond
that's empowerment that's it that's
empowering and her client lauren buford
seeing her potentially become a
justice is
inspiring
to be able to see yourself and see
what's possible she is overqualified
and this confirmation is overdue not
only will you make the court look more
like america but hopefully think more
like america she thinks like other moms
i've tried to navigate the challenges of
juggling my career and motherhood and i
fully admit that i did not always get
the balance right i love you so much
across the city the acceptance that
others are giving her just to be herself
is just a beautiful thing redefining
beauty that is an important
job of a supreme court justice isn't it
to redefine beauty standards that's what
we look the supreme court for i mean
that's where all the you know that's
famously people on supreme court a lot
of lookers on the supreme court famously
um
i i almost as absurd as all this is
really the line there about
that that escaped my notice during the
actual confirmation hearings but
uh that katanji jackson will help the
supreme court look more like america and
also think more like america
as if that should be the goal
no we don't want the supreme court it
doesn't matter if the supreme court
looks like america makes no difference
whatever that means to look like america
but also think like america what does
again i don't know exactly what that
means
but whatever it means i'm quite sure
that is not what we want the supreme
court to do
um that's that's that's sort of the
point of them not being elected
representatives
they're not elected by the people to
represent
precisely what we want them to do they
are put in place to represent the
constitution that is their job that's
their only job
it doesn't matter if the majority of
americans decide they don't care about
the constitution anymore
um that's still the supreme court their
job is supposed to be to represent the
constitution interpret it defend it
that's their job
all right one other thing i want to put
up on the screen before we get to the
comment section
so this tweet went viral um
a few days ago and uh
just want to read it
and we can all appreciate it together
it says okay i'm a trans woman who's
experiencing her first period cramps and
what the f
i've literally never felt pain like this
why do we people let people live like
this
by the way
91 000 likes on that tweet
and if you read the comments which i
don't recommend because it's it is
quite depressing
you find person after person including
women
responding to this male and said yeah
welcome to the club sister
now let me just explain this to you um
if you're a man
you cannot have a period
you don't have a menstrual cycle
you don't have a uterus
uh even if you grow your hair out
even if you
go to a a plastic surgeon and have your
your genitals mangled and mutilated you
still are not gonna have a menstrual
cycle
so the cramps you're feeling
uh i would seek a doctor about that or
maybe you just had chipotle you know
that's something that a lot of us have
been through
but if there's any if there's blood
coming i don't want to get into any
graphic details here but there's if
there's as a man you got blood coming
out of uh orifices or anything like that
that is that's not a normal thing
i'd seek medical attention immediately
but what happens then this does raise a
lot of questions because we know that
the the medical community now is fully
bought into
affirmation their job is to affirm
and so what happens i wonder
if this man
is is experiencing blood coming out of
areas where it should not come and
having um
you know bad cramping
obviously not a menstrual cycle because
he's a man he can't have that so there's
some serious medical problem happening
but he goes and talks to a doctor and
says this and says oh i'm having my
period is the doctor even allowed to say
uh no you're not because you're
a man
there's you know you might be dying of
something there might be internal
bleeding going on let's get can a doctor
even say that
without getting sued
i don't know um
maybe we'll find out so we've been
talking a lot lately of course about
inflation when inflation is at seven
percent like it is now the paper money
in your wallet is losing value fast you
can just feel your wallet getting
lighter by the moment that's why you got
to look at birch gold today an ounce of
gold is worth 1900 it was worth about
300 an ounce and 2 000. i've been
telling you for a while now that you can
buy gold from birch gold it's your hedge
against inflation but as you know
there's another way to hedge against
inflation that is silver you could buy
silver for birch gold as well silver is
also considered real money and
historically speaking it's extremely
undervalued right now it's an industrial
metal that's in high demand for
everything from electric cars to solar
panels demand is only going to rise and
some analysts suggest that right now
there's an unusual dislocation in price
that may present very real opportunities
for silver to rally over the next two
years regardless silver like gold is
never going to zero the american dollar
in the other hand well it's currently
going into the toilet while precious
metals are rising in value thanks to the
fed call birch gold they are the only
company i trust don't wait start
diversifying today text walsh to 98 98
98 to get a free info kit on buying gold
or silver in a tax sheltered account
there is no obligation to get this info
text walsh to 98.98 to get your free
info kit now
let's get now to the comment section
all right we'll do one quick video
comment this is clip let's go to clip
18.
hey matt
is this you
bruh
okay
so that's even worse than the uh
shirtless guy dancing on the golf cart
the shirtless fat guy
so this is allegedly me
um we're on a on a coveted testing
poster but you know no as i've said
a million times
okay am i gonna deny that there's maybe
some resemblance there
i'm not gonna deny it but
not every man with a beard and glasses
looks like me
okay i'm not i'm not just my beard and
glasses there's more to me
this this
makes me feel marginalized
along with everything
else especially
i i shouldn't need to say this but
these kinds of attacks that i suffer
are especially inappropriate now and
problematic given that i am
the best-selling women's studies author
in the world
all right this is from grenade away says
it's it's like will is a psychopath
laughing hysterically then mad then
tearful and grateful what the f
um no he's this is this is uh this is
just him being a cuckold you know he
laughed at the joke and they looked over
at his wife and his wife
was uh
upset about it and so then he he leaped
into action that that's all it is
but i but i will say you know
to his credit
that will smith's
wife's boyfriend
uh i think is no doubt very grateful
that he defended their their woman in
that way
um vicky says uh you laughed at the joke
then you punched chris rock for making
the joke then you're laughing after
punching him lost all respect for will
smith it's not okay to lay your hands on
anyone did you have respect for will
smith to begin with i think that's the
problem here
stephen says matt two weeks ago you were
you were just justifying violence in
response to insults especially to defend
your wife
well as you noticed um i have not said
there are other people that have said in
response to this that violence is never
okay in response to words
that's not my position i did not say
this that's not what i said now
that violence in that situation in
response to that comment
was obviously completely out of bounds
for a whole bunch of reasons we don't
need to get into i think we've already
talked about them
and we could just start with with the
basic fact here that you are
at an award ceremony
chris rock is there he's hired to get up
there and tell jokes about the audience
that's his job
and you have chosen to attend
this event where that sort of thing
happens
so no you cannot
that's not an occasion where violence in
response to words is appropriate
um but i'm not going to say that it's
never appropriate
of course it could theoretically be
appropriate
and when we talked about this i don't
remember the context we talked about
this a couple weeks ago the hypothetical
example i gave is if you're walking down
the street or something
and a guy comes up and sexually harasses
your wife
that's not what happened at the oscars
okay but if that were to happen
and you're out on the street guy comes
up and is accosting your wife in that
way
is it justified to punch him right in
his face of course it is
not only justified but i would say it's
your duty as a man to respond that way
so there is a little bit of a nuance
here
i don't think we have to take the
position that
violence
in response to a word is never okay
any more than we would say that it's
always okay
both positions are ridiculous
um
and finally lkn says matt i can't
believe you're actually buying this
obviously staged stunt
no listen
this goes to occam's razor all right the
simplest explanation what's the
explanation that requires the least
number of assumptions
and no it's not staged
occam's razor would tell us
there are no assumptions we need to make
to just accept this incident at face
value
the only assumption that we need is that
will will smith is uh is a
somewhat deranged egotistical cuckold
and he responded that way that's all
um
but in order for it to be staged
you know you have to believe so many
things including that like they would
they would
they would come up with a stunt like
this
to completely overshadow all of the
political woke virtue signaling they did
before this
so they put all that into the show and
then purposely overshadow it themselves
and then you have to believe that will
smith and chris rock the two of the most
famous people in america decided to go
along with this stunt that makes them
both look horrible and that they are
they're continuing to play along with it
i mean will smith is going to suffer
even though he's got people on the left
defending him and everything
there's no question that there's going
to be serious career
um
consequences for will smith because of
this
his whole image is as this kind of like
squeaky clean nice guy thing that's
that's his that's his bank ability to
the extent that he has a bankable star
it's all it all rests on that that's out
the window now so you're suggesting that
for the sake of a
of a skit on the oscars to help with
their ratings he would sacrifice his own
career
overshadow his own oscars win
i mean he won an oscar's first oscar and
all anyone's talking about is this
that makes no sense
it's that is far more ridiculous than
the actual incident itself
that's one thing people that buy into
conspiracy theories too readily
uh one thing you notice about them is
that they they oftentimes have just no
understanding of human nature
you have to understand human nature and
and celebrities and what makes them tick
and what motivates them they would never
take part in something like this
in that context
they're way too self-important for that
all right let's get now to the daily
cancellation
[Music]
so i've warned you many times on this
show including recently about the
pharmaceutical and psychiatric
industries and their mission which
they've embarked on together hand in
hand to methodically identify categorize
and medicalize every aspect of the human
condition
now this i believe is one of the most
consequential and catastrophic trends in
modern life it'd be difficult to
overstate the severity or significance
of this problem
life itself
what it means to be human to exist
this is all being redefined by
megalomaniac psychiatrists and
money-grubbing pharmaceutical executives
they have totally altered our image of
ourselves of what qualifies as normal
human existence
and they've done it for money
and because they believe themselves to
be gods who are somehow qualified to
make these kinds of changes to human
nature
now i've harped on this point quite a
bit recently and as if to prove my point
and justify the many cumulative hours
i've spent on it the american
psychiatric association has now
officially declared
that grief
is a mental illness
yes if you are grieving the loss of a
loved one you are mentally ill
but only if your grief is prolonged you
see
grief will heretofore be acceptable for
a brief length of time but if you have
excessive grief grief which lasts longer
than what is medically prescribed you
should consult a doctor immediately
now if it already disturbs you that
we're talking about grief the way that
viagra commercials talk about erections
then you're paying attention you know
because it should disturb you
yahoo has the news about the latest
medical or rather mental disorder to be
added to a list of 300 others
reading now it says as of last week
prolonged grief disorder officially
became a new diagnosis in the latest
edition of the diagnostic and
statistical manual mental disorders
despite the nearly decade-long debate on
whether grief should need medical
treatment the diagnosis became official
during a time when many americans
continue to experience ongoing disasters
that have caused death and suffering
such as kova 19.
now you may be wondering
isn't grief normal
isn't it the most human thing in the
world to have grief
isn't it an utterly essential if painful
part of the human experience
isn't the thought of a world numbed to
grief actually horrifying
isn't it literally something out of a
brave new world
well yes that's all true but you see the
psychiatrists and drug companies have
decided that grief should only be
allowed for a certain period of time
beyond that threshold a threshold they
have simply just invented out of thin
air it must be treated with medication
so continuing characterized by
incapacitating feelings of grief
prolonged grief disorder happens when a
person loses someone close to them like
a friend or family member within at
least six months for children
adolescents or within at least 12 months
for adults according to the apa
typically the bereaved individual
experiences intense yearning for or
preoccupation with the deceased person
so much so that their reaction to the
loss preoccupies them almost every day
for at least a month
a month
yes the psychiatrist will allow you to
feel grief for a month
just a month
before you're considered sick
in the head mentally diseased
lose your mother to breast cancer spouse
dies in a car accident child drowns in
the pool well you better be back to
normal in 30 days or else we're stuffing
drugs down your throat
but why should 30 days be the cutoff
well because as it's explained
grief beyond a month a month becomes uh
is a problem because it begins to
interfere with quote social norms
reading again
their bereavement is considered to last
longer than social norms think five
stages of grief causing distress or
problems functioning important aspects
of their lives such as socially or
occupationally other symptoms of
prolonged grief disorder include
identity disruption feeling as if part
of yourself has died
a marked sense of disbelief about the
death avoidance of reminders that the
person is dead intense emotional pain
intense loneliness emotional numbness or
a feeling that life is meaningless among
others according to the apa
now i don't think i can
fully describe
how much i hate this
i cannot sufficiently capture the
boiling rage that i feel deep within my
inner being
when i think about what these lunatics
are doing to people
though i'm sure my moral discuss towards
the pharmaceutical industry and
psychiatric community is also a symptom
of mental illness i no doubt suffer from
chronic pharmaceutical skepticism
disorder
if that's not in the dsm yet it will be
and if you have any doubts about the
motivation behind all of this the next
paragraph should clear that up for you
it says
inclusion of prolonged grief disorder
dsm means that clinicians can now bill
insurance companies for treating people
for the condition reports the new york
times currently clinical trials are
testing the drug
naltrexone which is a drug used to help
treat addiction as a form of grief
therapy and according to the new york
times the development will likely set
off a stream of pharmaceutical research
on other potential prescriptions
oh i'm sure it will
would you look at that what a
coincidence
the people involved in making up these
disorders also happen to be in a
position where they'll profit to the
tune of billions of dollars off of the
disorders they've invented
just a coincidence of course
meanwhile the apa put out a video
explaining more about the disorder
and the explanation directly from the
horse's mouth um doesn't sound any
better to me listen
what makes this different from normal
grieving is even though the symptoms
appear very understandable urine and
pining and and missing the person
desperately that seems pretty normal
after the loss of a loved one but what
we find is that those people who are
really stuck and have intense levels
even at the very beginning very intense
levels where they don't know who they
are without this person anymore those
people
often times a small minority
about four percent will not get better
uh they'll just spend and eke out the
rest of their existence missing this
person and wanting to be reunited with
them and that's that part is is not
helpful it's not helpful to ignore the
fact that some people get stuck
and could use some assistance and
support in reintegrating into a life
without this important person who died
it's not helpful
your grief is not helpful
let's just make a couple points here
first of all
nobody is disagreeing with the idea that
people in grief need and deserve
assistance and support
nobody's any problem with that i mean
we've always treated grief that way
there are support groups counseling all
kinds of different resources available
and which ought to be available and
that's good
but listen to the way nurse ratched in
the video is talking about grief
she says it's not helpful she speaks of
normal grief as opposed to intense grief
she talks about grief as a symptom
which says that it's a disease in which
the goal is to get better in the way
that you might get better after a bad
cold
this is all profoundly wrong
here's the reality
nobody
i don't care how many letters they have
in front of their name
nobody is in a position to declare what
sort of grief is normal
there is no normal or right way to
grieve
and even if you can look at all the
grief that all humans experience and
somehow categorize it and average it out
and come up with a baseline
that doesn't mean that every person who
experiences the loss of a loved one
ought to be expected to now stay at that
baseline level what kind of madness is
that well listen we've discovered that
on average most people grieve their dead
fathers for this amount of time so we'll
need you to keep your grief within those
parameters too anything beyond that is
just not helpful
the real mental sickness here is in the
deranged narcissist coming up with this
stuff
grief is not a sickness
it's not fun either it's painful
it can be devastating
i mean it can it can ruin your life
depending on who you lost and how it can
certainly change the course of your life
and it's possible that the sadness that
you experience will stay with you
forever for as long as you live
but just because this reality of life is
difficult that doesn't mean it's an
illness
that doesn't mean we need a drug for it
at a certain point our society needs to
understand this basic concept
not every difficult or painful human
experience
can be solved with drugs
c.s lewis wrote a book called a grief
observed after the death of his wife
it's a beautiful reflection of grief but
given that he was still deeply grieving
his beloved even after 30 days had
passed very unhelpfully
the apa would now probably say that the
book is nothing but the ramblings of a
mental patient you know a mentally ill
guy
he should have simply been given a heavy
dose of psychotropic medication that's
it
but in any case c.s lewis wrote that um
in the book he said that sometimes there
is nothing to do with suffering but
suffer it
meaning not that a suffering person
should be abandoned to their pain but
simply that some painful feelings the
deepest ones especially
must be felt
they must be experienced
there's nothing else to do with them you
could try to numb them into oblivion
that's not going to solve anything
it might make it easier for you to
reintegrate into society it might make
might be the best thing for the economy
and you know for your managers at work
but it's not the best thing for you as a
human being as a person which is what
you are
after all what is grief
well grief is love
deprived of its object
somebody said somewhere that grief is
love with no place to go
you grieve because you loved and you
still love
you can't make grief a mental illness
without making love itself a mental
illness because grief is love
now god forbid if i were to lose my wife
or one of my children
i would never get over it
i would never get better in the sense of
being back to normal back to how i was
before i wouldn't want to
i wouldn't want to get back to a life
where it's like they never existed
because i love them more than life
itself i would gladly die in their place
if that was an option c.s lewis said
that
grief is like an amputation you know it
does in fact feel like a part of
yourself is gone because it is
the psychiatrists now say that such a
feeling is abnormal it's beyond average
it's aberrant it's departing from the
accepted standard
but actually such a feeling is simply
human it's how a person feels after
losing someone they love deeply
a drug can't solve grief unless they
come up with a drug to raise the dead
absent that
the absence which causes the grief will
remain forever for as long as you live
and so you can either feel that absence
and have the pain which comes with it or
you can numb it with a drug so that your
loved one is still gone and you still
miss them but you don't feel it anymore
now i can understand the temptation to
seek refuge and numbness
but that's not what we should be
encouraging people to do
rather we should be helping them to live
with the pain to carry on in spite of
their grief and with their grief
the problem is that there simply isn't
very much money to be made in that
endeavor
and that's all these people care about
is the money
and that ultimately
is why the apa the pharmaceutical
industry
uh today are canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavovsky our
associate producer is mckenna waters the
show is edited by robbie dantzler our
audio is mixed by mike coromina and hair
and makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show ron
desantis signs the florida parental
rights and education bill into law
defying disney's woke virtue signaling
and joe biden no longer speaks english
or lives on the planet earth that's
today on the ben shapiro show give it a
listen